l'élection des délégués 1 bah oui je
voulais des délégués de classe parce que
quand les classes par le moins mal de
toi qu'on admire les profs et oui
forcément je voulais absolument de
délégué de classe mais il a fallu que
magouilles donc en fait ce qu'on avait
jeté avec un pote jalal jean mas c'est
mon meilleur pote à l'école et on avait
préparé des papilles avec que des
hanouna à vous avez vous réalisé soit
quand même les était donc qu'est ce
qu'on a fait donc à un moment ils disent
nous on va faire les et léguer donc à la
profession tableau alors qu'ils se
présentent ba ba voila brisson thomas
brisson un truc nicolas gratien et
hanouna hanoune est présent oui ce
présent qui se présente donc la nuit
vous noté sur un papier personnes pour
qui vous votez qui vont ramasser mois
jalal jalaladin ramasser ou est prévue
il avait une petite banane grâce et il
allait me tous les papiers et kalou là
dedans donc y ramasser les papiers lui
avait donné une petite corbeille lui
était un moment il fit ce subterfuge
ibrahim et les papiers avec anouma
dedans auquel arrive à nouna
hanouna